اغلبيه تقييد قاده الطالبان لما دخلوا الى
كابل اول شيء بداوا بداوا بالزواج المراه
الثانيه والثالثه والرابعه والجميع يتوز-
يتزوجون البنت المتعلمه
يعني هو متزوج امراه ريفيه واحده باثنين
لما جاءوا الى داخل يتزوجون من فتيات
متعلمه اذا كان هذا يمنع هذه اذكار يعني
انا متاكد تماما انا شيخنا محمد غير مقنع
بما يوقع وغير مقنع بما يقول
وجميعهم هكذا ولكن ايطاعه الامير لهم
والعوذ بالله ان اقول هذا الشيء
وكانه
الاميره
وانا اقول لكم شيء واحد فضيله الشيخ
فضيله الشيخ نداء محمد وزير التعليم
الطالبان
يقول
من يقول بان امراه تعليم المراه جائز
فلياتي بالادله وانا اقول يا فضيله الشيخ
نحن عندنا قواعد واصول فقهيه والقاده
فقهيه تقول ان الاصل في الاشياء الاباحه
الا ما ثبت تحرمه نحن لا ناتي بدليل لكل
شيء في الحياه انما انت الذي تقول ان هذا
غير شرعي وهذا حرام عليك ان تاتي بالدليل
والحرام بين والحلال
اذا كان الله جل وعلى امر الماء والرجل
سواء
باقامه بالامر بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر
ويقول سبحانه وتعالى والمؤمنون والمؤمنات
بعضهم اولياء بعض يامرون بالمعروف وينهون
عن المنكر المراه عليها ان تقوم بامر
بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر وان لم تكن
معلم وان لم تكن متعلمه وان لم تكن قد
ذهبت الى المدرسه والج وغيرها كيف تقوم
بالامر بالمعروف ونهي عن المنكر وكيف
تتعلم دينها واساسها وكيف تتعلم حقوق
الزوج الذي انت تقول انك
مقيم عليها ك- الرجال قوامون على النساء
فلا بد هي تتعلم ان الرجال قوامون على
النساء وليس بالكائن بالاكراه والاجبان
ليس هناك دليل في الشريعه الاسلاميه ليس
هناك حديث حتى ضعيف تمنع المراه او تفرق
ما بين المراه والرجل في اي علم كان